pra começar a falar um pouquinho da
mensagem que eu tenho é eu queria focar
muito na minha trajetória
primeiro porque os 10 anos de
experiência entre um pouco da minha
idade
a cada dia fica mais confortável eu vou
focar mais na verdade do que um
professor no ensino superior que é o meu
foco de estudo e trabalho nesses últimos
dez anos
não é a minha percepção é que cada vez
mais com a tecnologia
a praia que eu costumo trânsita já há
algum tempo desenvolver nossas soluções
é que o papel do docente tem se
deslocado com o central
quando eu comecei a fazer esses objetos
educacionais desenvolver esses projetos
no início da minha trajetória
eu fazia isso presencial
eu acreditava que as ferramentas
tecnológicas e eu chegar com força total
dentro da sala de aula e criar
ferramentas lindas os professores iam a
adesão fantástica
alguns deles se apropriaram disso a
tepco construiu grande primeiro projeto
até a reitoria da instituição que o
trabalho já postou neste projecto e um
professor da instituição na época luís
filipe e abraçou o projeto que eu
precisava de um docente nem a da
instituição ela tava durante o mestrado
fazendo isso quando eu criei esse
projeto quer uma espécie de simulador
virtual professor usar em sala de aula
eu lembro da primeira vez que eu tive
que chegar no auditório para falar de
tecnologia em sala de aula os
professores é duro difícil
se hoje é difícil falar
os docentes né imagina a 56 anos atrás
moc rede social foi antes do orkut pra
quem lembra do orkut
bem antes e no ensino superior ainda tem
mais um desafio é na praia de estudo
quando comecei a fazer tecnologia
educacional ii falava cara vai pra
ensino médio ensino médio e tudo mais
fácil você vai ter que conversar um pós
doutor com 30 anos de disciplina a usar
a ferramenta vai ser sofrível
falei não vou adiante e 3 sala um
professor adotou o projeto
luís filipe acreditou a gente usou
bastante a clínica né é um projeto de
uma clínica e interativa
esse projeto foi premiado um tempo atrás
e ficou em segundo lugar no concurso da
do mundial com esse projeto outros
trabalhos a gente vem desenvolvendo mas
isso sempre me incomodou e hoje me
incomoda mais ainda com esse
ressignificação que a gente tem dos
espaços de ensino principalmente no
ensino superior
cada vez que eu entro e eu me coloco
nesse nesse grupo de docentes claro não
me destaco disso que eu entro em sala de
aula
eu já tenho até medo de falar a
titulação não quero nem que permanece
pergunte isso que eu quero que a gente
fique igual ao de igual para igual e
essa é uma das grandes belezas da
virtualização do ensino é espaço para
protestar pra falar
liberdade é a liberdade que atua lida em
sal é muito comum chegar aquele pacote
de informação que a gente chega em sala
de aula e eu vejo e um reflexo disso a
resistência do docente ao ensino online
né eu coordeno o ensino a distância da
instituição uma base de 19 mil alunos
eu fico pensando onde está a fronteira
do real e do virtual hoje eu não sei
mais dizer eu não sei como alguém
consegue
toda vez que ouço ensino à distância
ensino online se no doi angustia porque
eu não sei mais dizer onde está essa
linha não sei como alguém pode afirmar
que essa linha existe entre o real e
virtual
é o próprio ted esse evento aqui a gente
está aqui no auditório assistindo mas a
grande escala de audiência do ted não é
presencial e online e como negar isso
como existia isso devemos resistir a
isso
eu lembro quando levavam essas soluções
lia ea palestra levar essas soluções
tecnológicas de virtualização
deslocamento do ponto de atenção para a
sala de aula para falar com os
professores doutores ph deixa a primeira
coisa que eu tinha que falar no meu
discurso não é a panacéia do ensino
hoje eu gostaria de afirmar que pode ser
pode ser hoje um aluno carente
o interior pode assistir o matemático do
limite anual isso na democratização do
ensino
isso não é ressignificação do espaço há
outra solução seria o que paga a
passagem pra todo mundo e permitir
acho que seria mais difícil ainda é
quando roda tenho mania de viajar de
carro roda interior do brasil e vou pra
bahia rodando as cidades vizinhas como
chegar nessas comunidades se não por
meio da tecnologia
a gente pode fazer um redirecionamento
dos docentes espalhar todo mundo pela
cidade vai ser difícil a gente tem uma
oportunidade de ouro agora as mentes que
mais tão qualificadas no nosso país para
colaborar com isso estão inertes
preocupadas com as publicações
publicações publicações publicação de
publicações
hoje a gente está aqui presencialmente
né
durante a palestra eu tava tirando foto
e já visualizando o que estava
acontecendo aqui
são imagens do nosso evento de hoje
alguns palestrantes que consegui
fotografar rapidamente subir no meu
computador botei de novo
coloquei aqui rapidinho né
esse tipo de coisa a virtualização é
essencial
a primeira coisa que vai bater na cabeça
dos docentes quando vê esse toque vai
ser você está falando que o professor é
inútil
não estou falando do professor é inútil
forma nenhuma eu tô falando que os
espaços e as relações de poder da
suposta detenção do conhecimento estão
se transformando a várias representações
minhas em sala de aula facebook cá como
apelido não sei como é chamada de carlos
henrique na apresentação
eu no linkedin ou num ambiente pelo
twitter eu fazendo uma vídeo aula eu
usava no laboratório todas as
representações de mim
quando você entra numa sala de aula
nós professores da sala de aula
colocamos um jaleco
montamos na saúde por exemplo as
bancadas de estudo configuramos os
grupos de trabalho
isso é real não são a representação da
realidade isso é tão virtual conta o
ambiente simulado dentro do computador
isso representa a realidade não se ouvir
muito falar
o aluno passa pelo ensino superior e
chega na empresa não sabe lidar com real
porque porque o ensino presencial ou
virtual em sala de aula os professores
virtualizam ensino são realidades
criadas planejados programadas 11
pacotes para entregarmos a onde eu já
não consigo ver discernimento entre o
ambiente virtual ele tem um ambiente que
a gente usa para ensinar uma disciplina
de cidadania por exemplo várias
disciplinas e uma sala de aula
presencial duas construções
eu não sei mas como separar o que é o
que não é
não vejo mas há como dividir que ali
está sendo ambiente construído
e na sala de aula não é um ambiente
construído é um ambiente construído
a diferença é que o professor na sala de
aula ou no poder
o centro das atenções
o ponto central do aprendizado e isso
cada vez mais está mudando
talvez o ponto de angústia do docente
maior que seja é justamente o
empoderamento do aluno o conhecimento
professor repositório de conhecimento
cara se você tentar competir com o
google está ferrado
não tem como existem muito mais coisas
interessantes que você fazer em sala de
aula do que pegar o potinho de
conhecimento jogar num outro potinho de
conhecimento não vai rolar
não é pra isso que a gente tem que estar
em sala de aula a cada vez mais o
conteúdo para para mim pessoalmente
parou de fazer parte do principal papel
que eu vou exercer em sala de aula
online
muita gente luta ainda contra isso
em 2013 2012 se eu não me engano
estimou-se que 7.1 milhões de alunos
frequentaram algum tipo de curso ou
educação e modalidade online ou os
professores estão certos
não funciona não é adequado não deve ser
aplicado no ensino superior ou 7.1
milhões de pessoas pelo mundo hoje e
devem ser muito mais estão sofrendo de
delírio coletivo
eu prefiro acreditar no delírio coletivo
é muito mais legal
olha só como o nosso olho treinado para
julgar o aprendizado ensino
você olha essa figura olha por algum
momento essa figura
se eu te perguntar de bate-pronto quem
está estudando se vai falar que é o cara
da garota do livro porquê porque quem
está estudando não casal falando no
fundo o que quem está estudando é a
menina no smartphone
porque você
o livro então todo mundo que estou com
você deve aprender um livro talvez o
livro seja um livro de romance ea menina
no smartphone esteja havendo uma
disciplina de cálculo
então pré-julgamento do que ensinar o
que aprendeu tem que mudar não pode ter
se você quer descentralizar empoderar as
pessoas você tenha treinar o teu olhar
para uma coisa diferente
essa figura aqui com essa onda toda
publicações artigos sobre o tema de
ensino virtualização me fala muito essa
figura aqui eu não fui um bebê nascido
no mundo digital gente pelo amor de deus
não conhece 10 anos de experiência e 37
anos é eu rebobinar a fita com lápis a 7
fiz isso nasci no mundo virtual digital
e aí os estudiosos da educação na hora
falaram existem os nativos
as pessoas que estão imigração
na hora que um só palavra nativo a
primeira coisa que vem à minha cabeça
que quando ele fala como um pesquisador
que provavelmente já é da minha faixa
etária professor fala os nativos
digitais
a primeira imagem que vem à minha cabeça
de um índio eu acho essa figura
fantástica porque imagino a
reconfiguração de uma sala de aula com a
docência no papel da catequese
acostumada a transmitir a um grupo de
joelhos o conhecimento sem
questionamento o homem branco que já
está meio que adaptado também não faz
parte do ciclo catedrático demonstrado
na figura pelos padres mas que também
aceita a imposição do conhecimento e o
famoso nativo que não poderia assumir
outra posição para o professor
no caso o padre
não fosse a confrontar estranhar a
atitude a agora o professor veio para
colonizar o nativo em sala de aula é
isso
essa é a posição do professor do ensino
superior vai fazer em sala de aula
colonizar os nativos que estão chegando
digitais
por isso eles são nativos digitais
índios da era digital rebeldes que
acessam o facebook durante a minha aula
é isso
a turma do facebook você vai tentar
competir com o facebook cara não vai dar
é impossível nem o facebook nem qualquer
outra ferramenta que eu tenho o conteúdo
se você chegar e botar na sala de aula o
tema
a célula em cinco minutos ele tem no ipp
ya provavelmente 70% do conteúdo que
você vai falar se ele procurar pelo teu
nome se você botou alguma coisa
divulgada na rede que compartilha hoje o
grande barato ele vai achar que você
escreveu sobre o tema
o ponto não é o conhecimento é a
motivação
aí o professor exerce papel fundamental
no meu ponto de vista e aí ele pode
abraçar a tecnologia mão contra os
nativos mais respirar o ar donativo
ouvir esse ano viajando pelo interior
o pescador falar pra mim caramba
impressionante vocês juntam dinheiro o
ano inteiro e pagam aqui pra ficar a
semana fazendo o que eu faço todo dia de
graça
o bom é respirar o ar nativo por que
você não abraça o lado donativo porque o
docente no ensino superior resistir ao
índio digital tem que se tornar aliado
disso essa figura foi feita na época
vitoriana
a vila é marco ti e ilustrando a visão
da educação em sala de aula no ano 2000
eu sei lá eu acho que se eu mostrar sua
figura na reunião de docentes
alguns vão querer a adesão a esse
sistema
isso me assusta muito
há alguns devem sonhar com isso vão
perguntar onde que vende isso é
exatamente o que não pode acontecer é a
idéia de virtualização de tecnologia do
ensino era essa e na cabeça de muita
gente continua sendo essa você tem um
cara e me desenvolvendo um software
aberto que ele compartilha conhecimento
é pode centralizar professor invista seu
tempo em sala de aula em coisas mais
interessantes do que chegar e botar os
livros no moedor e botaram vida do aluno
ele aprender
não faz sentido isso não teria
significado nenhum pra ele
a primeira pergunta pra que eu estou
estudando isso evidente a itaboraí acha
que o professor vai fazer hoje tem nome
claro oi tudo tem nome é hoje o flip
decréscimo as salas invertidas
eu aposto nisso aposto que a tecnologia
espalha a informação espalhou
conhecimento aberto gratuito do jeito
que foi feito por pessoas que não são
professores que são professores e o
professor desempenha o papel dele
criando relações significados para quem
olha esse é o papel que o professor pode
assumir no ensino superior para mim hoje
esse papel aproximar o aluno do real que
não é a universidade aversão à
universidade uma simulação como um
ambiente virtual a simulação
existe uma regra de design vai fazer
criação de produtos que ela fala em
conforto e satisfação felicidade até que
chega numa felicidade extrema do usuário
quando tem um produto
eu peguei visualizar essa regra cria uma
régua que é normalmente a régua que a
gente aplica nas nossas disciplinas
conteúdo ou tem que fazer isso aqui
método como eu vou fazer isso aqui
avaliação como eu vou avaliar isso aqui
eo grau que eu vou atribuir essa
atividade muito bonito pessoa ali
é o papá vamos rezar conteúdo meta total
concluiu
eu já acho que o conteúdo método de
avaliação
o grau de conteúdo método de avaliação
principalmente conteúdo método cada vez
mais responsabilidades do aluno uma
infinidade de recursos digitais vai dar
conteúdo método para ele com certeza o
do aluno a não vai ser o mesmo do aluno
b vai ser outro
isso é ótimo na sequência vai ser outra
isso é ótimo
a gente tem que repensar isso eles
ensino superior de como avaliação de
grau dessa reconstrução de como aprender
esse é o nosso papel como educadores na
no ensino superior
e eu penso num design de educação
confiança prazer em estudar o que está
sendo estudado significado estudar o que
está sendo estudado de qualquer lugar ou
em qualquer forma ea aplicação do que
você está estudando esse pra mim é o
design do educador uma nova modalidade
de mostrar o conteúdo das pessoas é uma
forma de abrir essa esse horizonte por
aluno
o real morreu
você pode assumir a posição nostálgico
em relação a isso ocorrer no grupo da
frente
modificar o seu cotidiano
eu tirei essa foto também aqui no evento
hoje quando eu cheguei eu botei meu lado
e trouxemos slides em branco é um
alinhamento com a realidade aqui com a
virtual
nem todo mundo que vai assistir a este
tópico é poder teve a chance de estar
aqui então alguma parte da aqui a gente
tem algumas coisas obsoletas nessa
máquina de escrever um projetor de
slides e se o professor
passar se apodera de cima dessas novas
tecnologias e as novas possibilidades
ele vai entrar na lista a entrar na
lista como mais um item obsoleto
eu vou finalizar citando uma frase do
maurício e daquilo que escreveu onde
vivem os monstros dentro de todos nós a
esperança dentro de todos nós
há medo dentro de todos nós
a aventura e diante de todos nós
existe um lado selvagem obrigado